Donald Trump wants to return to
Washington as president but he couldn't
get out of town fast enough after his
most recent court appearance claiming
the charges against him were about
blocking his route back to the Oval
Office when you look at what's happening
this is a persecution of a political
opponent this was never supposed to
happen in America
in a 27-minute federal court appearance
he pled not guilty to four charges
supporters gathered outside the
courthouse far fewer than protected far
fewer than the Trump Camp expected I'm
scared of John he's probably going to
get more popular
just as seen alone will make him more
popular right here
the former president faces four charges
three of conspiracy to undermine the
results of the 2020 election one of
obstruction his claims of voter fraud
and irregularities LED his supporters to
storm the capital trying to stop the
peaceful transfer of power his defense
America's First Amendment the right of
free speech he's already been saying
he's going to talk about the first
amendment that he had a right to say
whatever he wants and while it's true
you do have the right to say whatever
you want he went uh steps many many
steps Beyond saying whatever he wanted
is the actions that he took it's the
extra effort that he went to
three criminal indictments two
Congressional impeachments and a former
president who seen no real Damage Done
to his reputation among Republicans He
Still Remains the party's favorite to
win the presidential nomination and that
might not change even if he's got to
spend weeks off the campaign Trail
defending himself in federal court Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera Washington